a landmark study came out in 2005 and
showed that if you've used the blood
systems of old and young mice a process
known as heterochronic pyrobiosis
it rejuvenated the cells of old mice
it suggested that there was something in
the blood
and there were two possible explanations
either there were rejuvenating factors
in the young blood
or there was dilution of some pro-aging
factors from the old bloods
or maybe some combination of both
well since 2005 more studies have come
out
a 2016 study showed that heterochronic
blood exchange say just transfer from
young to old or older young without
fusing had a greater impact when old
blood was given to young mice than when
young blood was given to old mice
in better words the inhibitory effects
of old blood are more pronounced than
the benefits of young so somewhat
rolling out factors in the young bloods
but even more support came from studies
published a few years ago where again
they supported this latter theory
you see simply diluting the old blood
that is taking out the plasma of blood
out of old mice and replacing it with
saline and albumin an abundant protein
found in blood
had the same effect
this process known as neutral blood
exchange involves no frankenstein
surgery or young blood vampire-like
scenario amazing
but it still didn't address why or how
the authors of that paper left us with a
rather interesting hypothetical
hypothesis graph of what potentially
might be happening to some factors
present in the blood but they were
otherwise unsure in what or how these
beneficial effects were being achieved
what were the important factors to
remove
well we now have some more answers
but before we get to that we must first
talk about senescent cells
no not because i researched them i think
they're really interesting
but because they are relevant to these
new findings
so senescent cells are cells that have
entered cellulosin essence
this is a cell state that cells appear
to enter in response to irreparable or
chronic damage
the cells stop replicating become
bloated and decrease the variety of
factors into their surrounding
environment such as growth factors and
inflammatory factors
for i'll explain a video here
our current understanding is that the
secretory phenotype has function
it is involved in signaling to the body
to respond and react to the damage that
perhaps cause the cell to become
senescent in the first place
so senescent cells are important for
wound healing
and afterwards are removed by the immune
system
however senescent cells have been shown
to accumulate with age and cause chronic
inflammation that has been linked with
aging and disease
so called inflammation
and so the secretory phenotype is
interesting in this context as these
accreted factors are present in the
blood
moreover previous work has shown that if
you transplant sonata cells into young
mice it causes premature aging
phenotypes
so could senescent cells and their
secretory phenotype be linked with the
plasma dilation experiments
well that brings us to this latest
publication systemic induction of
senescence and young mice after single
heterochronic blood exchange
so what they did here is perform
heterochronic blood exchange between old
male mice and young men lies
after just one of these exchanges the
author showed that the aged mouse blood
induced senescence in the young male
mice
so that's all good me saying but where
is the evidence
and what happens if the experiments were
repeated but the old mice were first
treated with analytics
well just to get everyone on the same
page let's first just recap what's
actually in blood
well firstly we have the red blood cells
that carry oxygen around the body
let's have a round of applause
then we have the white blood cells and
platelets
responding to wounds and infections very
important and then we have the plasma
the soluble fraction of blood and it
contains water ions proteins like these
inflammatory and grey factors but mainly
an abundant protein called albimum
nutrients water again
more water gases hormones
yeah our blood carries a lot
and so you can think of blood as a
transport and communication channel
and so in heterochronic plasma exchange
all these components are moved between
the old and young mice without diffusing
while a neutral blood exchange they just
took out and replaced the plasma with
saline solution and albimum
all right
so now for the data
they were interested in looking at how
senescent cell incidence
the present was affected following blood
exchange of old and young mice
and to do that they used a special
genetically modified reporter strain for
the young mice that light up when
senescent cells are present
following 14 days of blood exchange they
see a significant increase in the whole
body signal in the young mice receiving
old blood
so looking at the young old eu mice yes
we're calling them miami's data points
now a little brief interlude you may
think like me the results seem somewhat
underwhelming
as sure we can see an increase but it
isn't really that much
but actually that is probably what you
would expect
figure 2b looks like the young mice have
not gained many senescent cells but the
young mice are well young and you
wouldn't expect many
plus this is 14 days after the exchange
perhaps the immune response of the young
mice has already removed some of the
senescent cells it would have been nice
to see a few more time points
but anyway back to the data they then
analyzed the old blood and found that it
contained higher levels of some
classical senescent secretory factors
such as interleukin-1 alpha
interleukin-6 and tnf tnf-alpha
looking at other physiological markers
they found that the yeomies had
increased fatigability and shorter
treadmill running distance and they had
increased liver fibrosis and renal
damage
so what about if the old mice were given
synalytics before the plasma exchange
for those of you unfamiliar cenolytics
are supposed to selectively kill
senescent cells
so what happens then if senescent cells
are removed from the old mice before the
blood is exchanged
well they used the cenolitic combination
of the satinib and quercetin and gave it
to the mice for five cycles lasting
three days separated each time by a week
unlike in the previous case in the
cenolitic treated old mice
there was no senescence transfer to the
young mice
there was also an improvement in grip
strength and treadmill distance compared
to before
and these findings indicate that the
senescent cell clearance attenuates the
negative effects of old blood on energy
balance and on the impairment of
physical activity
now they don't pin down what exactly in
the old blood is having this impact
though they say that following this
analytic treatment blood transfer the
mice had reduced levels of several susp
factors the secretory these senescent
secreted factors
therefore it does somewhat suggest a
positive feedback a downward spiral of
doom where senescent cells secrete
inflammatory factors that can induce
senescence in other cells that then
secrete more inflammatory factors that
can then induce even more cells to
antisenescence and so on and so on this
is known as paracrine inducing essence
however it is unlikely to be that simple
since the authors also looked at old
mice receiving blood from either old
mice or old mice treated with analytics
and found that it didn't reduce the
senescent markers
or refers the loss of muscle strength
renal damage or liver fibrosis
indicating that there are senescent
unrelated factors in the blood
and so things are still quite unclear
and i think to further consolidate this
we basically need to see the plasma
dilution experiment repeated instead of
this heterochronic plasma exchange
why
partly because of the controversies
around young to old blood transfers
though that said we should be
encouraging more young people to do
blood donations to save lives
especially if the blood is less likely
to induce senescence and recipients who
likely already are dealing with some
serious illness or accidents but also
the fact that therapeutic plasma
exchange is already approved by the fda
there is also the big limitation in the
study that they only looked at male mice
and not female mice partly to avoid
hormonal complications but that is also
something that could be interesting to
look at
and then again this is all in mice
though there is some human data where
they took human plasma from young and
old individuals and added them to human
cells in a dish
there was a greater increase in the
abundance from inflammatory factors when
old plasma was given compared to young
plasma so it's in line with this
paracrine induced senescence model how
the secretory phenotype of one senescent
cell can cause other cells to become
senescent
and so all in all
mammalian aging appears to be driven by
the excess of systemic factors that
include sasp so the senescent secreted
factors and the attenuation or removal
of these factors is expected to yield
new therapeutic strategies for health
bank extension
and so if you got this far i guess
you're interested in age referral if so
you should check out this video here and
three different strategies being
investigated
anyway with that i hope you've learned
something thank you to my patreon
supporters and thank you for listening